that thing is activated in cars
large-scale destruction now it's cut I
go to work
hi I'm Mike simul from FX guide.com for
wired with the new show agent Carter
Marvel expands still further into the
television space and they're not the
only ones that are moving to the small
screen visual effects for the new series
were done by Industrial Light and Magic
now traditionally ILM only did visual
effects for films but now they're doing
series and brought their considerable
talents to episodic television under the
supervision of series VFX supervisor
scheana Diggle
no newcomer to the Marvel Universe
herself Sheena has done second-unit on a
range of Marvel films from Thor to to
Iron Man 3 the problem that Sheena and
the ILM team faced was producing the
effects at feature film level on a
weekly TV schedule effects range from
everything you might expect from a
period drummer set in the New York in
the 1940s and a huge range of effects
that would obviously only be at home in
the Marvel Universe as we can see here
as Peggy Carter deals with another one
of Howard Starks inventions complex
fluid particles and smoke simulations or
using ire lems academy award-winning
proprietary tools that required a huge
range of effects with just this sequence
alone Island pulls no punches in their
detailed work major effect shots such as
the oil refinery explosion are
painstakingly crafted out of multiple
layers of practical and primarily
digital explosions with smoke fire
sparks all being added and tracked in
carefully to give the sequences the kind
of production value that audiences have
come to expect from both Marvel and to
ILM
the primary challenge actually for ILM
was not the effects themselves but this
punishing TV schedule and constant
delivery dates to facilitate this well
controlled green screen and set
extension work was shot while all of the
work being filmed by one cinematographer
Gabriel Barristan who Gina had actually
worked with extensively before
interestingly Sheena
actually worked herself as a composer at
ILM
mid 90s so it's great to see ILM
expanding the television and given the
nature of this shows particularly strong
independent female lead it's also great
to see women such as Sheena in such a
senior visual effects leadership role
today well don't forget to subscribe for
more behind the scenes action I might
see more for why
you